all right blue devil
yeah blue devil uh where'd you grow up
where are you from originally
originally uh i was born and raised in
the city of hawaiian gardens
i never really got jumped into the
neighborhood just really like
running around with the wrong crowd long
time
parents just shooting me up with heroin
you know
at the age of 13. your parents were
addicts yeah
and see my own brother hung himself take
his own life
and i was only like about six
when he passed away right in front of me
then at the age of 13 i ended up doing
heroin
just and i try and shake that as much as
i can
it's a hell of a childhood it is and
then getting thrown against the wall
like when i was a baby
by my mom it got to the point where
the more i did something good
the more i got hurt and the more i did
something
negative the more i got more rewards
what was your parents background were
they in gangs or
nah to be honest
like they were just
young at an early age trying to have a
kid and didn't
really know how to handle everything and
they just did the only way that they
knew that would fit you know
yeah so
that's like and
and the best way that i could describe
it would have to be
some like my my mom didn't really know
how to be a mom
at that age how old was your mom when
she had you
uh like 16 or
like 15 yeah
so it's like you got to understand like
it's kind of hard
harder for her because she didn't want
to have me
and then when i when i tried going up to
see her she still don't want to have
nothing to do with me so i just left it
as that
never wanted to come back and have
anything to do with her
then after i i started kicking it with
the homies
even though i never got into any
neighborhood i always kick it with the
homies
got busted in and out in and out 14
years straight
how do you know 32 with two strikes
that was that right you're going to walk
a straight line now
yeah i'm trying to walk a thin line man
but it's hard
but it's like
every morning i wake up and i'm like man
i wonder what it would have been like if
i would grow up in a peaceful
environment like a nice family when i
said no i had to get like
a worse side you know can you even
imagine that
i try to i try to imagine how it would
be
if i were to actually uh want to
get back into school instead of staying
out of school yeah how far did you go in
school
i graduated after graduation i got my
high school diploma
went right back to county jail
at 18. and then
uh got out went back in
got out went back in and
caught a strike got out
and then i just barely been out with my
second shake
for like about a month so you're just
fresh out of prison
yeah what kind of stuff got you into
prison
hanging out with the wrong crowd you
know fights
like not really wanting to do anything
productive just wanted to be
negativity just but what kind of
offenses
what was it drugs or was it not like uh
i stabbed someone during broad daylight
in the middle of the crosswalk
and the first one was for
robbery and
i in reality all i could have done is
just been i just let that [ __ ] go by
but now look at like i have to learn the
hard way
and it's not fun like when you have to
be in and out of prison cells
in your own shelly or whoever you're uh
no that's going to canteen and you're
over there starving
because your own family and friends
forget about who you are
the minute you get busted you know do
you have any contact with your family
today i burned every bridge of my family
and i had nobody to blame on my own
and it's like i'm starting to see the
things that i messed up at and i
actually made
amends and i told him that i burned my
bridges
now it's time for me to remake my bridge
you know
it's great for you to that you're
willing to take responsibility for
for your situation even even though you
didn't pick your parents
yeah i like i'll tell you straight like
nobody put a gun in my head and
said do this i did because
i felt like it was right thing at the
right time at the right
place and the right person are the right
persona
for that moment you know so i just went
by what i knew best
since i've been hurt so many times i
just felt like all right since i've been
hurt
let me hurt other people so that way
that i could get the way i feel out and
let them know how i feel
do you feel like the the lack of
parenting and
even the abuse that you may have had as
a kid kind of led you down
the path you took yeah
really did it really did
because
[Music]
if uh my parents were more in my life
hanging out just in my in my corner
actually fighting for me
and my ringer like i would have been
growing up
probably to be like what like at least a
little bit better than i am now you know
yeah there's a world of possibilities
for him yeah and there
is there still is yeah you almost need
to repair it yourself
this is my this is my last strike and i
i mean this
like i'm fighting like hell like i'm
fighting to
literally like keep up to stay out of
parallel because
getting in and out of prison acting like
that's the thing it's like
where's the honor and that like you
could see the scars
tattoos that i have i don't got no
trophy ain't got nothing chauffeur but
scars and tattoos
and i and it's like
something in us has to give us that
change
like what is it that really feeds that
fire
for you to want to get that fuel to
change
it could be either getting a
little job or
making a job
like they see me with tattoos and all
that and be like oh no no no
but then once they get to know me
they'll be like oh this guy ain't bad as
he looks you know
yeah it's just like uh
i basically changed the guy in the
mirror who i'm looking at you know
and it's like
yeah i have
originally i i'm like
the fifth one i have five brothers
and one sister on the baby and all of
them got like good
jobs and everything and me
i'm i'm just better to get out free
and and my sister just barely had a baby
but she wanted me to be the godparent
but i told her how am i going to be a
god partner but i can't even take care
of myself
let alone a kid she just looked at me
like
that's some real [ __ ] like you know
because do you have kids a girl you
don't
no because how am i gonna have a kid if
i can't even take care of myself
a lot of people do it a lot of people do
but i'm one of those ones you're not
taking care of their kids but they're
having kids yeah
don't get me wrong it's good to have
kids but if you're gonna be there the
whole time
yeah being here but it's like parent
being a father are different things
oh yeah it's interesting though
you're one of the few gang members i've
talked to that
still has you see you're hanging on to
that
idea that you you deserve better
we all do we all do yeah but it's
interesting that you're like talking
about it thinking about it
that's that's that's the first step and
then you start
taking action towards that yeah because
at that point you have to hit that point
where you get sick of being sick and
tired of waking up in that same corner
and it's like
in the pen i was even in there like
lost doing heroin and you know
[Music]
it's all bad it's like at the same time
i got up and i was able to kick the
heroin and throw it away like if i were
to see it
i would just be like i want i wanted
something better than that i'll just get
it and
flip it and turn it into food so i would
have something to show for
not something to you know is it hard for
you to be you're living down here on
skid row now
is it hard to be around all the drugs
nah
to be honest first three weeks
it was hard it was hard as hell
but after like four or five weeks later
then they already get to know you like
all right you're trying to stay clean
once they get to know who you are then
they'll be all right cool
respect that they support the fact that
you're trying to
change direction yeah that's great
and that not too many people really had
that installed in them you know
thank you and the ones i do is just like
someone asked me that they like
don't you ever want to try and have a
castle night because i'm not where you
are
having too much of a kid as much as i am
having my life back you know
i rather have my life back because maybe
down the way
i might want to adopt a kid or something
and give him a lifestyle that i never
was able to get you know
so basically
like everything that i wanted through
life was like no
no no no no no no but now
i could turn around and be like here you
go you know like it goes this here goes
that
that's what i wanna like i told my
professor like
when i get out i'm trying to work with
the military
because the military live the same
lifestyle as we do
we eat we sleep and we dream in a war
zone
but the only thing is the actual
military
they fly overseas and us we get to go to
the corner
or whatever and come back home and they
have to stay out there for a while
and i have brothers that were like like
i said like one of them was in the
military
hunger cell now my other brother just
barely
like got involved in the military so as
soon as i found that out
that's what what makes me want to give
more to like
to the veterans than to people that are
just trying to like do some
you know there'd be a great change of
direction for you
yeah and once tomorrow he's like
and you just like what the hell like i
never heard any [ __ ] like that you know
yeah i've done a lot of these talks i've
heard very few guys in your situation
speaking like you are yeah thinking like
you were
and uh now the worst
now the point is that
i tried going out and getting uh my ebt
card
i'm still arguing with them because they
haven't sent my ebt card so i'm still
trying to like hustle off scraps or
whatever
i can get you know like whatever i can
do to get my life
positive you know i know like
here and there everything's not gonna go
planned
but doesn't mean that we have to follow
that direction
we can make it turn or we can make it
how we want it
where do you think you got this these
these
ideas that you're talking about was it
was it time in prison
yeah time to think to yourself the whole
time of prison
and like what really made me think more
is when we had the whole kobe lockdown
because we weren't even able to go in or
out of ourselves or anything you know
and i was just like man like
thinking in like what what's better than
this there's
got to be something better than this
life
like because
something's got to be going on with my
life
better than it is now so many guys from
from the streets end up they always say
you know from getting the gang passed
we'll say uh it's either prison or death
yeah it is it really is with this
lifestyle
it's only a one-way street
you don't know you might get the left
hand and you might get the right hand
blue devil i appreciate you coming in
and sharing your story
all right i wish you the best of luck
with your new direction man
thank you sounds great thank you very
much
all right
you